in a rare TV appearance queen elizabeth
is remembering the day she was crowned
nearly 65 years ago one thing that
stands out the quote horrible carriage
ride that took her through London it's
part of a new documentary airing Sunday
on the Smithsonian Channel
Charlie Daggett is outside Buckingham
Palace with an eyewitness account of
that day in 1953 Charlie good morning
good morning to you picture the scene 27
year old Queen Elizabeth arriving back
here at Buckingham Palace tens of
thousands of people lining the streets
to have a look one person doesn't have
to imagine because she remembers to she
was right there on that momentous day
when Elizabeth became Queen Elizabeth
Lady and Glen Connor was literally an
arm's length away as a maid of honor
that's me that people say was hell
waiting the most special day I said what
actually it wasn't it was the coronation
we had to go she was only 19 at the time
and still proudly keeps her dress at
home and while she and Elizabeth were
childhood friends that wasn't the only
reason she was picked we were chosen
because we had good figures we were the
right height and do you really think
that's true of course it was it was like
a production it was like making a film
you know I mean in the coronation the
Queen chairs for the first time her
memories of that day including the bumpy
carriage ride horrible there's just no
it's only sprung on liver so it rolls
around a lot it's not very comfortable
were you in it for a long time halfway
around London really we must have got
about four or five miles I can only go
to a walking pace you know the horses
couldn't possibly go any faster right
it's so heavy
although documentary maker Alastair
Bruce says he was a little nervous he
said Her Majesty made him feel welcome I
think people are always surprised by her
humility
she is not sitting there waiting for
people to bow and curtsy she's not
bothered about that at all she is keen
to put people at their ease and she does
say with great gentleness even so lady
Glen Connor admits to being a little
star-struck when it came time to play
her role there was a queen we hadn't
ever seen her in our coronation dress
we're all waiting there and she just
turned round she said ready girls
Emmys of naudi's I off we went and she
says nothing will ever compare to the
moment she joined the new monarch on the
balcony you could actually feel
physically feel there's a Robin and the
noise coming out - it was extremely
feeling and they were mad about I've
ever said happy now in the documentary
to be shown this weekend the Queen joked
about how heavy that crown was she said
you had to be careful about leaning too
far forward you might break your neck
and lose the crown Nora
Charlie d'Agata at Buckingham Palace
thank you and the coronation airs Sunday
night on the Smithsonian Channel which
is owned by the Smithsonian Institution
and Showtime which is a division of CBS